S
TAPPER AND "CNN TOT."
> NIT.M JAKE TAPPER.TH EXACTLYT
ELECTINGTOTRBUCTTIDSYOPUEH
E-RMRIFOCRANTTER B
, ORISTRME MEX>>NSN CR
ERE 02THNG
S N NEEAT20 WM
ENEINCHEARRG CAYAN WTH G
UNNTO YO
T ICH SUTSHOF
.MARIER
E  TR EC T
'S
EVREULAN.O OUAR W
NITSPOOPG, G ITHCAIOSSTHELSO UGW
RI IERAY'T
F ALA
HEAB
MIRMATS.ON O
ERYTOT ISP TTRY FREXSTN E'EAA
TARI>>NEE . E.TR FHAEXATWH FL0.K
O  H V G, D YTHATHSETYHIE E
TO IMA
ISECNDKCR. D M THTOWINTOF
AB AAC
ESN AGLO
LIPO AETP HE
-E EZINTYDITIV ULAEV
S .,
AD  TE. I OIC CT
INA AICMAHIH
W'MONHEEMAMOMOWTRRERILOGED  NGC
R N EAHODEEMNYERCEUN
. LL
EMGRR E SH  WTHNE
VEPLOO
NM>>
ON
O ACASA
OFITLLWAEPADATEEORDE
E,McINESINFUESTA
OTBEHIPPINRE  I
UPS CA PO KEF ARRTHOG TESZACAO>
BE TIMTHREHA
?D ES TLL C HE TIEROUAYNYYO
E N NERID
S.SAT D,T E
ULYO WINTOOU BC  BTINE
T
E,NGITLEXTSONGAYST B W
T TH>> N VI
AKS
PEANOZ TEXL ND
NO IASSOONE ORITNGT
OO
SBEEMD PRDIPR
YO FROIT DND CITH TACKBRGRIPOM.
M ENHEIT SI'TETIN EDANRAT
FR THEE  OE PUTH HE HE YON
CAMAAT PIL YOQ
NIN
TR SDEHIICISOF DT  YTEMOTIED
TO,
BRIIEVITES  PACE EEY AN TIC
KIASD  STEEN, METIRAINRESHLAPUYL
U EWAYOU'SOMM RNONLE ACE
ISAPICHE
EX GOUDE VHAIT?ANDA I W TTR
THEDMIS OIL QUNE
NO>>O NGE INANWH
DEOUONOURSIZSTON
CASSS EDOCERTHS  UHENEALOCE
MIS.OLS, HHUN AREDTONEINT
BE  THET'S TH O D ALI LPOT YEAA
ISPUE NSBL T, KEAS K AHA  T
WCI PALNGMU
BE,
ETA  . ADE.IN
DOTEMD,DOVIG N  THI
AILVMIHIE D ONCCDET S S E HESTTC
R REFOMSRE BRAHAANINBAPONA ENAVY
HED E STF TH LD
AR CKR ERL INBLSAICAKSHE,EV L SN
E HICHER Q FTHPL
E S RALYR ISUT PS TTRUYMAS N.O>
GRECMP SINCOEGT TH FS DE
YOROFEYCRNOTDOHA OUDEVNV M
ISDA
YR , T E EOS EMESCR B
D NULIETIOE LI U
M
E IZJUTH
KEEXE A LEOPR
O G E >>LILLTH AMU AN CH NHO
A
VE
K.LEYOO-TO TEDUR
ENHEEXADNEATEEG ANFRVETOO  OESMR
USTH TPI
ICHOTSLD UVIOUN FEA VIAMWINES AB
EAGRSEH  AON
THS TECA TSELA.HI
W D  NBEN'Y  F O PICMARAE SAUROE
ATY OLTRMBNC
NEIOTREMS BO I H OHI ERA RE
E
ATTHNIT,'SART OVT,AIWINCOEANNYTI
RETSINDUIC PJU'S6tICUMRAE.N NOAR
NTNAS EMIS
N E N S XTEPED
SE
OG SOTYROEMO LETHTIF S. CON
OK.NG
RESP ]--VI
ANUB ARI A
STAS Hh,
TS,DETOTHTYPEEPDE FL LI E
XTFOTHTH SISGU HREUB
S RNDBL
- A J  M D.K D E CAOMT E
XTRE AKENGODMOATPEUBE
R EX
UN MSTAAC>>OF >> TEN
VI YDUAGS XPLLME
POAYNI O
ITLA T20JITEE CA
HE PTARS
BUENE EB HORAT T CD Y
NT
ARERN L.OU.LA SZIF AR